Hollywood, here we come!
The glamor!
The celebrities!
The scandals!
I’m not talking about Bennifer or Brangelina.
Craig: Are they still things?
Nick: No...
Craig: I'm kind of out of touch.
But I'm not out of touch with the Golden Age of Silent
Cinema, when stars rose and fell, studios
perfected the mass production of films, and
American movies dominated the global film market.
In some ways, it was very different from the
Hollywood we know today.
Movie studios wielded enormous power.
They kept stars and directors under tight
control.
The movies they made were silent.
And a ticket would set you back a whopping
10 or 25 cents.
On the other hand, a lot of the patterns set
during this time still seem awfully familiar today.
Studios marketed films on the power of their
stars.
Genres like gangster movies and romantic comedies
took hold and flourished.
And audiences craved gossip about the private
lives of celebrities.
To understand the world as it is, sometimes
you have to go back to where it all began.
And for Hollywood, that’s the Silent Era.
[Opening Music Plays]
Film was going in a lot of different directions
after the First World War.
In Germany, filmmakers drew on the Expressionist
movement to manipulate their film’s mise-en-scene,
creating groundbreaking horror films.
In Russia, Soviet filmmakers were using cinema
to perfect the arts of propaganda through
revolutionary editing techniques.
And in the US, the Hollywood studio system
was positioning itself to dominate the rest
of the world.
Within film studios, the entire filmmaking
process took place – from conceiving, writing,
and shooting the films, to marketing and distribution.
The studios had chosen California for its
film-friendly sunny weather, its proximity
to all kinds of terrain, and ... its distance
from Thomas Edison, who spent much of the
1910s fighting for control of the American
film industry from his base in New Jersey.
In the early days of the Silent Era, three
film studios ruled them all: the Famous Players-Lasky
Corporation, which would eventually become
Paramount Pictures – Loew’s Inc., which
began as a theater chain – and First National
Pictures.
Not only did these three dominate the marketplace,
they exercised near complete control over
the creative and personal lives of their stars,
writers, and directors.
Filmmakers often had to choose between following
the studio’s orders or abandoning their careers.
Then, four of the most powerful figures in
early silent cinema came together to create
their own film studio.
In 1919, two directors – Charlie Chaplin
and D.W. Griffith -
and two stars -- Douglas Fairbanks
and Mary Pickford – founded United Artists.
Their goal was to give filmmakers more control
over their films and a greater percentage
of the profits.
CHA-CHING! Is what I assume they would say.
Of course, not many filmmakers could afford
to go out on their own like that, so the contract
system would continue for several more decades.
In 1924, the most powerful studio emerged
when Loew’s purchased Goldwyn Pictures and
Louis B. Mayer Productions to create Metro-Goldwyn-Mayer, better known as MGM.
Which lead to MGM studios which lead to Tower of Terror,
and have you been on Tower of Terror? That's a pretty fun time.
This is a process that would get repeated
throughout the 1920s and 1930s, as studios
merged or sold or split apart.
Probably because of prohibition and they didn't have anything else to do.
By the end of the era, most American films
were being made at studios whose names you
might recognize from the multiplex today:
not only United Artists and MGM, but also
Warner Brothers, Fox, Universal, and Columbia
Pictures.
Now while the corporate structure of these
companies kept changing, the process by which
they were making films was becoming remarkably
stable and efficient. Unlike me.
The major studios became very good at churning
out large-scale, commercial movies with mass
appeal.
One of the leading innovators in setting up
the way studios worked was a man named Thomas H. Ince.
Like D.W. Griffith, Ince came to film as a failed actor.
He directed his first film in 1910, and by
1913 he was making as many as 150 two-reelers
a year!
His biggest impact on film came by applying
the lessons of mass production to the actual
making of movies.
Prior to Ince, most films were overseen by
a director-cameraman – a single person who
conceived the story, worked with the actors,
and operated the camera.
Ince broke those roles into separate jobs:
A screenwriter to conceive the story and write the script.
A director to make creative decisions on set
and work with the actors.
An editor to assemble the footage.
A producer to supervise the project from inception
to final cut.
And a studio head to oversee the entire studio.
While other filmmakers had played around with
these roles, it was Ince who standardized
them into a system – a system still used
today.
By 1912, he’d earned enough money to buy
a ranch west of Hollywood where he built his
own studio, a place he called Inceville…
Yep!
It was here where the first permanent exterior
sets were built, made to resemble far flung
locations, like a cowboy saloon, a little
Swiss street, or a Japanese village.
And as Ince worked to define the roles and
streamline the means of production, he was
able to triple the output of his studio.
Though he died quite young in 1924, Ince’s
impact on film production was as thorough,
widespread, and lasting.
Now, Mack Sennett, another early film mogul
and one-time partner of Ince, was responsible
for discovering a whole slew of film legends,
whose names you might recognize.
People like the Keystone Cops, Fatty Arbuckle,
Gloria Swanson, Carole Lombard, W.C.
Fields, and… the great Charlie Chaplin.
Let's talk a little bit about Charlie Chaplin.
He was born into poverty in England
in 1889.
He went into acting, signed with a prestigious
Vaudeville touring company, and set off for
America at age 19.
A film talent scout spotted him there, got
him hired by Sennett, and the rest is history.
That we're gonna talk about because we're talking about Film History.
Smart, curious, and driven, it didn’t take
long for Chaplin to develop his iconic Tramp
persona and begin directing his own films.
After finishing his first film contract, Chaplin
struck an extremely lucrative deal with the
Chicago-based Essanay Studios to make 14 short
films.
While at Essanay, he found ways to combine
his finely tuned sense of empathy and his
recognizable Tramp character with a growing
ability to make audiences laugh – through
both physical comedy and increasingly clever
storylines.
In fact, he was so popular that by the time
his Essanay contract was up in 1915, he negotiated
an almost unprecedented salary of $10,000
per week with another studio, the Mutual
Film Corporation.
They also paid him a signing bonus of $150,000
– the equivalent of about $3.5 million today.
CHA-CHING! Is what they would have said at the time.
The movies Chaplin made with Mutual brought
him international stardom.
They marked the first time his focus on the
poor verged into social criticism, a place
silent comedies rarely, if ever, went.
True to his roots – and despite being one
of the highest paid people in the world – Chaplin’s
films often focused on the gentle, accidental
heroism of the downtrodden.
Time and again, he made the powerful the butt
of his jokes and displayed tremendous empathy
for the poor and the humble.
Then in 1919, at age 30, he co-founded United
Artists in an effort to exercise greater control
over his films.
I'm 36... I better get moving.
What followed was a string of classic movies
that rank not only among Chaplin’s best,
but among the best film comedies of all time:
The Kid – his first feature film and a smash
hit – The Gold Rush, City Lights, Modern
Times, and his controversial take-down of
Adolf Hitler, The Great Dictator.
His later career would be hampered by legal
problems and socialist sympathies, which would
land him on the infamous post-war blacklist,
and keep him from making films.
But at his height, no one benefited more from
the Silent Era studio system than Charlie
Chaplin – as a director, making a lot of
films quickly and efficiently; and as an actor,
commanding enormous salaries and unheard-of
creative control.
And he wasn’t the only one to turn this
system to his advantage.
Actor-directors like Buster Keaton, “Fatty”
Arbuckle, and Harold Lloyd achieved great
success making their own short and feature-length
comedies.
Stars from Mary Pickford to Gloria Swanson
parlayed their celebrity into tangible behind-the-scenes power.
Now, as film became more and more central
to popular culture, some people started to
get nervous.
They worried that movies posed a real threat
to public morality.
They saw films promoting materialism, cynicism,
sexual license.
This would be a debate that would
come up again and again in American culture
– about movies or music or video games.
Until now when we've solved all those problems.
Is the medium causing society’s problems,
or just reflecting them?
A few real-life Hollywood scandals at the
time tipped the scales, bringing on the first
real self-censorship of American cinema.
The gossip press fed readers stories about
stars dealing with addictions, affairs, and worse.
The most famous of these centered around Fatty
Arbuckle, who was accused of the rape and
accidental death of an actress named Virginia
Rappe.
Although he was ultimately acquitted after
three highly-publicized trials, the scandal
itself all but ended Arbuckle’s career,
and left an opening for a government crackdown
on immorality in films and the film business.
Rather than wait for Congress to get involved,
the major players in the film industry banded
together to form the MPPDA – the Motion
Picture Producers and Distributors of America.
They hired a retired Postmaster General named
Will Hays, a conservative Evangelical, to
prove they were serious about cleaning up
their act.
And that’s exactly what Hays did in 1930,
putting together the Motion Picture Production
Code, also known as the Hays Code, a catalogue
of things filmmakers could and couldn’t show on screen.
...fun.
The Code also suggested a strategy called
Compensating Values.
The idea was that films could show characters
engaging in vice for most of the film, as
long as virtue triumphed in the end.
No one employed this technique better than
director Cecile B. DeMille.
He was a master at giving the audience all
the vice and excess they could handle for
the first three quarters of the movie, before
virtue came out on top.
Other filmmakers found their own ways around
the Hays Code.
German director Ernst Lubitsch came to Hollywood
in 1922 and made a successful series of witty
sex comedies that relied on suggestion and
innuendo rather than skin.
For many of these filmmakers, however, the
Hays Code was about to become the least of
their worries.
A seismic event was poised to shake up Hollywood,
and not every filmmaker of the Silent Era
was going to come out the other side with
their career intact.
The world was about to get its first taste
of synchronous sound.
And it tasted good... maybe, I don't know.
Today, we explored the Silent Era, the first
golden age of Hollywood filmmaking.
We learned about the innovations of Thomas
Ince and the rise of the American film studio.
And we discussed some of the most important
Silent Era filmmakers and how their scandals
– both real and imagined – led Hollywood
to institute industry standards governing
the content of their films.
Next we’ll tackle the biggest shift in the
history of film yet, as movies find their
voice... es...
Crash Course Film History is produced in association
with PBS Digital Studios.
You can head over to their channel to check
out a playlist of their latest amazing shows,
like The Art Assignment, Gross Science, and
PBS Infinite Series.
This episode of Crash Course was filmed in
the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney Studio with the
help of all these Industry Standards and our amazing
graphics team, is Thought Cafe.